mmm-hmm sorry we're late did we really
eat dude I hate I hate being late man
I hate being late but I'm always late
dude I'm late for everything I'm on dude
and when you show up late you got a make
you got to make up for it I think that's
one of the reasons I kind of maybe when
I was young that I became like kind of
you know gregarious or out God
everything's going wrong today I think
that was one of the reasons why I became
like like you had to develop a person
you know you had to develop like you
know be you know entertaining the people
or because you were late look if you're
late bro you [ __ ] better make people
happy fast man you know like I just cuz
you have to get into like oh you know
yeah you guys got here early and I'm
like [ __ ] no we didn't you're late
[ __ ]
and uh but anyway
well sorry I'm late dude ahahaha what
let's see if um if I can make it up to
you thank you guys for your patience uh
let's see what's going on
celebrate
celebrate ms
have some fun while we all die celebrate
our day
celebrate all
Oh
let's have some fun while we all die
there you go and that is celebrate that
is the that's a Spencer Jacob growl band
GRA you and and that's a wild last name
ground you know some people you know we
used to have a boy buzz named Danny boom
the last name was boom some people's
names there are sounds their last names
might be sounds you know or even their
first name might be pop we had this old
dude used to coach t-ball and then would
pop jörgen pop jorgens
and he was uh his first name was a sound
you know pop boom Danny boom you know
Larry splat they had the splats he's to
live about four blocks down from us
Larry splat and his family and the funny
thing about them was they were real real
then so it almost seemed like they'd
followed the whole family just fallen
off of something just landed and kind of
just you know Larry splat like that but
so some people have sound names and that
that man who made that song for us as
one of those maybe Spencer Jacob growl
even though it is GRA you so that's
probably Dutch I think and it's not
growl you know we used to have this uh
we had a teacher when I was in seventh
sixth grade or something named barb
growl and uh and that's it so that's an
interesting last name barb you know last
name growl
I'm is a growl because it sounds
especially when you're a kid if you hear
that your teacher next year is gonna be
Miss growl like growl a scary though
that's scary that's like you know who's
your
teacher miss murder miss Donnie tram
murder you're like damn I got miss
murder and Miss growl I am [ __ ] but
yeah some people can have an interesting
first name or last name pop Larry splat
dah
Danny boom latisha murder no Donny
forgot it that lady's name barb growl
interesting names man I'm you know I'll
get him some of these fits sometimes man
I'm came in a fit today I don't want to
talk to anybody I don't want anybody
[ __ ] looking at me I don't want
nobody touching me dude sometimes you
know the dude I feel bad for the person
that touches you and you don't want
somebody touching you there's probably
about usually 30 minutes in my week
right on one nobody dodging me yeah
don't touch me
and somebody some [ __ ] grabby Mick
[ __ ] Richardson will touch me and
don't I turn in a [ __ ] barb growl
real quick boy I started just barb
growling at people and I'll turn in the
[ __ ] Miss done tisha murder don't
even do that boy I'm gonna Larry splat
johast Donnie boom Danny boom alright
that's when I lose it bro that's when I
lose it and today was one of those days
when I came in here everything was
[ __ ] everything you know the studio
is all a mess it just looked like a damn
trap house is just treacherous you know
and it just I came in and I just wasn't
in a good movie I didn't help that was
the problem I didn't try to help the
scenario I just kind of complained at
Nick and uh
and
you know I just whatever you know that's
why I meant that's where I'm at
but I'm grateful to be here today to at
least get that off my chest and just say
what's going on and I had a long night
you know I had a long night man I um you
know I like here one thing I look
forward to at night time I look forward
at night time so just to finish my step
mouth off from earlier if you are late
then you have to have some semblance of
communication really you know you have
to develop um I think people that are
late can sometimes develop the ability
to be entertainers because you have to
make up for the absence you know you got
to cut a couple of jokes or do something
you know tickle somebody's ass a little
to do something you know you got a
[ __ ] you know lightly pin you know
you got a whistle it's on the back of
somebody's neck real softly just boy
[ __ ] hailing cabs off the back of
somebody's like an upper lumbar dog on
that neck you blow on somebody's neck
boy my god boy make that cartilage make
a lot of cartilage show up in my wiener
suddenly if somebody you blow on my neck
boy
make a lot of cartilage show up in my
wiener area but this is what I'm saying
here is that I had a long night and I
look forward to nighttime but dude look
I look forward to nighttime because I
get to rest and I get to dream and I
like doing those things so here's what
happened to me I had a dream that my
[ __ ] neighbor and let's be honest a
neighbor is just somebody who bothers
you that's close as [ __ ]
that's where I'm at to him just [ __ ]
mmm I just wanna make sounds like that
Larry splat barb growl up so I'm feeling
so my neighbor I had a dream and my
neighbor lost their car keys and wanted
me to help look for him so I'm all ready
to have a dream you know and but in the
dream not in real life in my dream
but dude I spent my whole dream helping
them find their [ __ ] keys uh their
car keys and here was the worst part at
the end they had sold their car somehow
you know how dreams are suddenly
something just [ __ ] happen you know
you know you know how dreams are you
work you know you'll be in a dream you
or your order a glass of lemonade next
thing you know you're [ __ ] you know
you're on Mount Rushmore it's like so
this whole night my entire night I'm
helping my neighbor whose apartment
smelled like liver and onions I'm
helping them look for their car keys
then finally I can't even if we got him
or not but they realized that they had
sold their car so that was my whole so
that's my night sleep so not I had not
only you know and I woke up probably
four or five times so not only did I not
get the rest I wanted but the dream I'm
getting I have to work during it I had
to work during my whole dream helping
somebody look for car keys to a car they
sold in a vast expanse of liver and
onion smell and man so I showed up today
and I was just kind of chirped out I was
kind of chirped out
so that's why Matt did I like to have a
dream where I can relax you know have a
pineapple pop have a um you know a
couple of maybe you know some cheesy
breads or something chill out go on a
plane ride but like a real slow playing
that's calm calm calm calm calm calm
plane so that's what I like and but if I
got to stay up all night in my dream I
got a B dream and then I'm [ __ ]
looking for your keys and you ain't even
got a [ __ ] car you animal then that
makes me mad I thought I got taken
advantage of a little bit so so that's
why I'm mad I'll give you a little
update on life on my side oh I saw
Gerard Butler this weekend again at the
Comedy Store and and he was super nice
man he talked about we chatted after the
show for a little bit and I've seen him
before here and there we have a mutual
friend and and uh and he had lost his
house he had lost his a Malibu home in
the fire and one of the fires out here
and he was telling me that you know he
was upset it was obviously devastating
but that you know suddenly he had to get
a new place and and right around the
same time he and a girlfriend of his
girlfriend had split up and so suddenly
his house is gone his girlfriend is gone
and he had to rent a new house then you
know obviously he's blessed to be able
to have the ability to you know just
rent a new house but he just said you
know he had kind of a positive attitude
he said you know it's just like he kind
of got forced into like a new experience
and and he was just kind of rolling with
the punches so I thought it was just
kind of an interesting take on you know
on a real tragedy but uh but that was
interesting I saw him at this economy
store this weekend I had a eye infection
all weekend or you know we're shooting
the pilot last week and I'm
put some clips up on patreon today for
mine some images from the pilot chute
but we're shooting the this Comedy
Central pilot which is based on the
podcast how awesome is that
man I'm so grateful coming the it's
based on the podcast so the podcast you
know it's people that have called it in
the podcast you know wanting to talk
about an issue that they're dealing with
or it's sharing something that's going
on in their life or expressing concern
for a friend or family member and now we
are taking those calls and meeting with
those people in real life and going out
and helping find um not solution because
I don't know you know I don't really
have any solution but helping be a part
of their lives and just letting those
people know that I care and that
somebody cares and that we care you know
so that's really really cool that now
you know this community that we started
here it could potentially be a show you
know it could potentially be a real show
and there's a couple episodes and that's
called man up that are on YouTube but
now we're making a few more and we got
some good stars in Joey Diaz Coco
cocksucka he came out and helped out
with me and have gotten a sweat lodge
and and who else Jon Lovitz you know he
came out who else we might have Jim
Jeffries we got to do one more episode
but anyhow the makeup they had a makeup
lady working the first day and she I
mean one thing I like about whoever does
that if I work on a on a project or I
say project like I'm some kind of
[ __ ] actor if I work on one of these
deals bra and they what I like is the
person that does the hair the makeup if
they have a good energy and a fun vibe
then that really starts Monday off well
because if you whenever you go on a set
on one of these on a set of a taping you
know the first person you go see is hair
and makeup you know in hair damn do good
luck with this with this [ __ ] this
straight up man this [ __ ] is it
straighter
my shits getting Brazilian dude my [ __ ]
is getting straight-up Amazonian I mean
I'm gonna be selling weed on the beach
soon but the first thing you do go to
the hair and makeup chair so and if that
person has a fun energy and a good
energy and [ __ ] then that's great the
day is great you know because that lifts
you off so anyhow the makeup person was
just to me was kind of dull and but even
worse than that whenever they were
putting makeup around my eyes and look
dude don't look at me like I'm wearing a
bunch of makeup man I don't wear makeup
you know the only thing I've ever had on
my face most of my life is acne when I
was young acne or my big nose outside of
that bro that's the only thing you find
on my face except maybe you know a
little bit of chocolate around my mouth
if I have like a chocolate and a hurry
and I'm not being real careful so so
anyhow this lady was kind of dull but I
think one of the tools she used to put
the makeup on or something they had
dirty you know they had dirty tools you
know like I don't know she's out there
sharing needles or something with other
makeup people you know she's out there
in the [ __ ] back out and he's in
these L'Oreal back alleys I don't know
she's been in these you know these Estee
Lauder trap houses or what you know I'm
saying I don't know she's you know I
don't know she's copping Grahams you
know but you know in the basement of a
Sephora or what's going on but the
makeup whatever she put it infected my
eye my eye got infected so then I'm
rolling around with that bad eye and do
if you have a red eye I don't care if
it's I don't care if a bee stung you and
your eye I don't care if like a little
mouse bit you but you know if a little
mouse [ __ ] you and your eye dude I
don't give a [ __ ] here's what other
people think they think you got pinkeye
then you got some of your booty in your
eye and that's man it's hard to shake
that because you need you gotta have
when you look at people if you only have
one of your eyes open they thinks you're
being weird
and they're right so anyway I wore an
eye patch and I had you know I'm trying
but finally it's going away so it's
getting better but so it's just been a
hectic you know all day all week and I
had to have an eyepatch on and I look I
like I've has mental [ __ ] and do you be
surprised the ladies that want to trying
to [ __ ] climb up your ladder you know
they want to try and climb up your
little ball or you balled up meat ladder
when you have an eyepatch because I I
Pat is like hey guess what's behind this
patch who [ __ ] knows maybe buried
treasure
maybe a little jewel you know a lot of
old senior citizens are Persian people
they put a little jewel back there they
put a ruby or a um amethyst they popped
that little [ __ ] in that I wear to I
used to be you know when some of them
you pop that thing open if you could if
you could open up eyepatch on somebody
why they sleep and you can [ __ ] Jack
them you could steal all their you know
all that are they got orbital they got a
lot of jewelry just [ __ ] sometimes
sitting in that orbital area you [ __ ]
cop a couple of jewels out that [ __ ]
earn you a wedding ring or something
just because you snuck up and lifted a
low patch door so I mean eyepatch used
to be a lot more popular when I was
young you know I think they probably had
about 70 people had eye patches now it's
probably got 30 people so it's you know
it's a real different time people is
afraid to wear an eye patch because they
don't have pirates and stuff anymore so
it used to be you had an eye patch hoop
or like oh it's kind of like a pirate
now it's just like what you know just
get a glass eye or just cover one you
know
some of these people they don't want to
use eye patches because of the materials
they say they're wasting materials by
building um by making an eye patch and
people want to just some people would
even just like real poor people when I
was young they would paint their hand
black and just put it over there hi to
save money and I remember that but
anyway so I'm in Rock an eye patch I
came in here just you know a long night
of [ __ ] helping my neighbor find keys
that don't exist in a subconscious and
um and that's why I meant that's where
I'm at man that's where I'm at with uh
with life so the super bowl happened you
know look I'm happy for the Tom Brady
I'm happy for the Tom Brady but also you
know and look I'm happy for the
organization they won they won the game
they beat I mean that look they beat my
homes they beat the Rams they bit they
did it all so there's no discredit at a
certain point though it's like you do
want to see something different you want
to see kind of a new experience than
you've seen you know I like to see a
changeup I like to see the underdog now
I don't think there was an underdog in
this game I think either one of those
teams could have won that game but I
like to see more of an underdog I like
to see something just kind of different
than we've seen of late but no shade to
New England man and no shade to
Belichick that guy runs an organization
you know even if they play unfair 10%
unfair everybody's trying to play unfair
everybody's trying to be sneaky now one
of my favorite parts was when Goodell
came out and everybody booed his ass I
thought that was great um you know I
really though that's really the part
that got me but only watch the ball
probably 13 minutes in a game I was
switching between that and a so dove
Dateline called into the sand or
something Dateline has the weirdest
names for all their episodes doesn't it
you know the missing arm of Brooklyn you
know or not without my daughters or
secrets in this
secrets in the Serengeti or uh at the
bottom of a lake it's always like a
weird clue about where the body is
you know oh something's in the chimney
it's always something like that you know
like Oh bones in the baseball diamond
and you're like oh wonder where the body
is what else is happening man I saw this
wild news story it was about about this
guy Jesse Smollett and and all of these
and he was a Empire actor who who um
allegedly was attacked on the streets of
Chicago and it just seems like a fake
story and I think he's I think this guy
is black and white actually he is a yeah
he's mixed he might be Middle Eastern
mush for what ethnicity is I mean he's
at least part uh I would say he has a
little bit of an Arabian look possibly
but he's either he's like probably mixed
but um but this [ __ ] just seems so fake
it's ridiculous man you know he was
attacked they can't find any video
footage they've looked apparently and a
lot of this is a legend it's it's it
they've looked at a lot of you know the
police departments looked at a lot of
different tapes and just the from
different areas he was at a subway it
was below zero they threw bleach on him
they threw bleach on him and they said
that they they yelled racial stuff and
make America great again stuff it's just
in the thing that makes me a most upset
about this sort of deal is look I'm not
surprised at anything that comes out of
Hollywood you know I don't believe half
of these claims I don't believe half of
what I hear out here but you know when
you are when there's already issues of
race in America and there's already
people that really are getting at
by different ethnicities because of
their ethnicity to do something like
this is just too much and it's not fair
it just really minimizes well it's just
first of all it's taking advantage of
something that's really Civ it's really
it's really selfish if you were using
those things to gain acclaim for
yourself because a lot of you know a lot
of trial and error has gone into into
like integration and segregation and
racial you know just like you know
America is slowly building its way out
of you know the tough spot that it was
in from slavery and you know when you
have you know when you have somebody
who's just kind of it just minimizes all
the the I feel like the advancement when
you use these things for your own value
to try and get ahead now I can do I
think something could have happened in
this guy yeah he could have fell outs he
could have fell down you know I don't
know how they said he's throwing it
somebody threw a liquid on him and it
was like five it was like five degrees
or something so I don't know who's
running around with a liquid chasing
this young guy it just all sounds crazy
and they put a noose on his neck dude I
mean I just I mean come on man it just
at a certain point if something seems
too unbelievable then if then it you
know it's just like that's where it
lands and so many black you know DD on
the news somebody black like youtubers
and news people have come out and said
this is ridiculous man you know so it's
nice to see that people aren't just
siding with their own race anymore that
people are starting to say okay well
this seems fake on this and this seems
fake on this and it doesn't matter who
you are
because that's a place where I think you
know that's a great place to be at
because then we're all can be moving
forward you know we all can be we're all
judging each other based on what's going
on right now and it's I think you know
and I feel sorry for this young man as
to why he feels like he needs to do this
if he's trying to it just seemed too
much and then he put out a video the
other day or somebody did of him he
called himself the gay to POC that he
fought back and I don't know
it just seems like somebody really
taking advantage of um you know a lot
has gone in and that meant a lot of
people of sacrifice their lives a lot of
people have you know done so much to get
race relations into a good place and in
a lot of America they are the only place
they're not really that great a lot of
times is in the news you know I hate the
fact that the news always just focuses
on you know just they'll you know
they'll find the one you know idiot
redneck or and they'll always focus on
that guy you know we're not redneck but
yeah just some racists you know real
perv doubt dude he's out there jerking
off on little you know black statues in
his yard or something and they find that
dude and it's like man that's the
there's so few of that dude left I wish
they would sometimes focus on people who
you know we're that they wouldn't focus
on that but this just seems like um I
don't know it just went cool man it's
just not a cool thing to do there's
other ways to increase your you know
your visibility and something could have
happened to this man I think he could
have you know III sicko could have hit
him maybe a hard cook you know it was
snow and a couple hard snowflakes could
have taken this dude down I mean he just
copped a subway sandwich they said and I
don't know if it was that meatball hit
or what it was but you know I mean it
could have been aa turkey add turkey now
if he's at Jimmy John's I could see
somebody jumping his ass for a Jimmy
John brothers [ __ ] are good but ain't
nobody [ __ ] beatin you ass in the
middle of the night randomly like they
tracked you there nobody's tracking your
ass daddy
nobody's ain't nobody beatin nobody's
ass for a Subway sandwich
now Jimmy john-boy come outside [ __ ]
even one of those on what's that other
one that weird wouldn't that's kind of
out now it's Oh Jersey Mike's that [ __ ]
taste taste like your cousin [ __ ]
spit on it at the end but you know and
it's old the meets a little wet but even
that I could see somebody coming at your
boy Fred maybe and you know if they're
real hungry but here's why non-belief
jealous aw but here's what I believe
Jessie smile at because ain't nobody
know Bar ID
whooping nobody's ass in zero degree
weather for a damn subway bro you know
that [ __ ] ain't nobody trying to get
nobody subway Sam winch on now that
Jimmy john-boy somebody running around
with a turkey tom with extra Turkey son
I'll [ __ ] it
you know I'll set a tripwire on the
sidewalk for it I do you know [ __ ]
tase somebody for a damn you know for a
full length Jimmy john-boy I like them
Jimmy John's you feel me
I like that Jimmy John with them
tomatoes and them [ __ ] pickles on the
lawn baby you got me but come on bro
get right dude and don't use you know
all to use something that that is that
powerful just for your own gain that's
just [ __ ] up bro it's real selfish so
I think they need to investigate this
guy's ego anybody whooping nobody's
asked for a damn subway bud you know and
the good thing is is that this guy is
multiracial so everybody should be
ashamed of this man behavior but then at
the same time we've all done [ __ ] so you
know I can understand how your ego can
get out of control and you could do
things but this is a little bit much
when you're using things like that that
are that important because what if
somebody now goes on the street and they
go attack somebody because you did this
there tree they get you know some crazed
Empire fan or something and I've never
even heard of this guy so and maybe he
may be enough people hadn't heard of him
and that's why he's doing this in the
first place but it's just uh it's not
nice man and it's selfish that's what I
think
now I could be wrong but you know in
[ __ ] I could be wrong and if I am wrong
man I'm you know I mean I don't know
this guy he don't know me but if I'm
wrong then yeah I'm sorry but but it
just feels real [ __ ] fake bro anybody
beat nobody's asked for a damn subway
anyway today's episode I got to tell you
and I'll say this about Jesse Smollett
he's got nice hair he has very nice hair
and hair is important and your
confidence is important and sometimes
one change can make all the difference
hair club knows this and they're
inviting you to become part of their
hair club family to see how getting the
most out of your hair can change your
life hair club understands the emotions
you're feeling and knows the questions
you have Hair Club is the leader in
total hair solutions whether you're
looking to revitalize growth of your own
hair or to learn more about the latest
proven methods for hair replacement or
restoration hair clubs professionally
trained stylists hair health experts and
consultants will craft a personalized
solution to ensure your best and get the
most out of your hair
see for yourself go to hair club.com
slash Theo today for a free hair
analysis and a free take-home hair kit
all valued at over $300 that's hair
club.com slash Theo th EO for a free
hair analysis and free hair kit hair
club comm slash Theo experience your
hair and your life at its best
only with Hair Club I'm certain you'll
love the club and everybody knows I've
had that hair you know I've had some
hair care done on me you know I'm trying
I haven't washed my hair in about two
weeks though what else is going on man I
wanted to pop into a little bit more
news we got the super bowl we got just a
smile let um what else I think that's
about it man you know I think that's
about it in my life what's going on
what's going on man oh I'm thinking
about getting a ps4 and that's not a um
some people think that's an inoculation
it's not it's a or a vaccination it's a
video gaming system in ps4 dude they got
everything I was in the basement of the
comedy store the other day and they have
an area down there we can relax and play
games I didn't really know it was down
there as much but man i sat down and
played something you know big gun or
some [ __ ] were you just shooting people
uh no damn zombies dude enough fought
some bees for like an hour and it was
one of the most relaxing things that
I've done in a long time I'll tell you
this man presale tickets for Boston
there's another show we're adding in
Medford because the Boston shows on
Friday night have sold out so on the six
I believe the 7th of February which is a
Thursday know of March sorry the 7th of
March so the 8th of March is sold out
the 7th of March we are adding a show in
Medford and those presale tickets those
will go on sale Wednesday this Wednesday
and the pre-sale coda is Boston and I'm
excited man I'm excited to get there
hopefully some of the Patriots fever
will still be in the air man I died well
I will say this man nobody throws the
Baltimore white dudes than Tom Brady
brah I mean that guy should get a ring
they should give a ring at the end of
the season for whoever can complete the
ball to a white dude with that many you
know really active black men out there
that [ __ ] is challenging his funk dude
dude yeah it's very challenging so ain't
no bones about that [ __ ] man so he
should get that he [ __ ] completed
like 13 passes to the little white guy
that little dude I thought that guy you
know that dude who knows bro sometimes
if he to go that far was that dude the
first time I caught one ball out of a
run right off the field and sold that
[ __ ] on eBay but he's out there
hustling
so but yeah man I've been tired dude I'm
in dealing really well with my own
stress I'm thinking about taking a week
off in uh around Valentine's and going
on a retreat or something this weekend
I'll be in Columbus though I do want to
let you know that I also have we're
gonna put New York tickets on sale soon
Australia is coming up February 11th
those are go on sale so next week I'll
let you guys know what cities and where
we got some new Rat King and gang gang
shirts up on the store Theo von comm
slash store and what else dude any other
good news oh I went to the urgent care
and they had a couple ladies in there
they were nice and they got me some
eyedrops to some I can get better I'll
be at the San Jose improv March 22nd and
23rd I'll be stand-up live Phoenix
Arizona March 29th and 30th April 5th in
Kansas City and April 6th
April 26th and 27th in Palm Beach
Florida and then May 3rd and 4th
Caroline's on Broadway in New York and
that is it man that's what's going on I
want to thank everybody for your support
we had a couple calls that came in let's
get to a few of those really quick the
number is always to reach out to is nine
eight five six six four nine five zero
three yeah man it's tough I've been in
this weird space where it's like I'm
tired but I also know I need to be
active so it's like I'm not getting
enough rest but at the same time I'm not
taking care of myself enough like on the
other end of the spectrum I keep in my
blood going and just staying active so
you know I just been feeling like a lot
of stress man I've been feeling I think
a lot of us just fear us you know you
know things are going busier now and
like it's just scary
you know it's like I used to you know
and I talk about this a lot but it's
like yeah it's just scary no it's cool
but it's just a little bit scary um you
know and then just dealing with other
people like even just little things like
I sense the other day somebody said hey
man we sent a video to my friend for
their birthday or something so I sent
him a video and the parent the friend
was a fan or a you know not a fan but
you know I don't really like that word
that much but just somebody who is
interested in my humor and uh and then
the next day they like put it on there
in staccato I don't know just just
little dis things were you like oh okay
well that's you know that's you know now
do I got to be careful if I send
somebody a personal message just that
they're gonna I guess I don't have to I
still can just be myself but yeah just I
don't know just kind of scary it's just
a lot and it just feels kind of you know
oh you know I feel just nervous a little
bit
you know I don't have a manager right
now so I just have an agent and and I
have enough work because we have these
podcasts and I'm grateful I have the
King and the sting podcast now which is
you know we're learning as we go do that
podcast I get in there and I feel like I
get like I get mean in the hair like for
this I can riff and everybody up but
it's fun dude it is fun I mean uh
Brendon is fun because you know he had
me come over to his house to watch some
of the Super Bowl and really we just
talked about work and hung out but it
was it was really cool it was really
cool man we had you know somebody in his
family is Mexican and he'll it might be
him and they made a superbia I don't
know if you ever had a sober beard I do
but
[ __ ] el dia de los des ru nose bro I
was a full oh it was so good man a [ __ ]
it was so good bro it's just like
somebody just punching you in the face
with a bunch of [ __ ] good [ __ ] at
once punching you right in the mouth
with it um anyway that's what's going on
in my life man
you know what else oh I was thinking
about mother nature dude think about
mother nature imagine this imagine you
driving down the road and you see a lady
right she lay in there she got them big
Tatas out you know them [ __ ] big you
know milky love seats just just kind of
leaning off each side of her chest you
know and she gots animals all over her
she got her you know a little raccoon
we're running out of her crotch you know
she got a little you know some ants
she got a like an anthill on her leg you
know she got you know trees you know
growing out of her shoulders and she got
you know raspberry bushes just right up
onto her chin that's mother nature bruh
she got a [ __ ] snake around her neck
and the snake is eating them little
pieces of uh
you know um cucumbers that's mother
nature
imagine you kind of roll one of her you
know lift one of her titties up a little
bit and they got a damn uh you know a
couple of oysters and mussels under
there and they got a little fox with a
little hammer trying to beat those
oysters open so he could have a little
lunch snack that's mother nature man
imagine she got fresh water just flowing
between her breasts you know and she got
salt water just you know him brackish
around the neck that's mother nature man
imagine her hair just made out of just
long vines you know just getting all out
of wilds flying out of her head imagine
that in her eyes they made out of
quartzite and gold and fool's gold
and shale that's mother nature
I mean imagine you pull up and see that
bad bench on the side of the road would
you you know would you try to [ __ ] you
think or chill man that's the question
right I would chill
I would chill man I ain't trying to be
like that I'm not trying to be sexual a
mother nature man I'm not like that
that's crazy that's absolutely crazy man
you need to get your mind out of the
gutter Oh
today's a wild episode man I don't even
know if I'll fully woke up you know it's
hard to wake up when you've been [ __ ]
looking for somebody's keys all night
[ __ ] okay let's say a couple of
calls as always the hotline is nine
eight five six six four nine five zero
three I'll say this man so we're doing
the man up you know the episodes now in
real time out there and we got to really
have I mean two great experiences with
some young men this weekend or the last
week it was awesome you know it's so
funny like I've just constantly reminded
and this is one thing I really should be
really grateful for is that for somehow
my life I'm constantly reminded of the
joy that comes when we spend time with
others when we really give of our own
time to just let somebody know that we
care even just by being there instead of
just saying I care or this or that or
liking their thing on instagrams if we
say hey you know just be there be there
with them be there to listen you know I
was talking to one of the young men
where we're working with and he reminded
me of so many things you know as a young
man he struggling with um you know his
father passed away when he was young and
it really I think
and he's you know he stood he lives with
his mother still and you know he hasn't
really kind of grown up
about 30 now and I and it just you know
and my father passed away when I was
young and so I could relate I could
understand some of that and they
reminded me of some of that and actually
you know it really it taught me about
some of the you know moments that I've
never really you know I'm so oblivious
to the world I think when my pet mom my
dad passed away that I didn't really I
wasn't able to really get a view of how
I reacted to it or what it meant to me
or what was going on or how I behaved or
anything but by talking with this young
guy and seeing what was going on with
him I was able to kind of get a vision
of what that what that can be like
sometimes for a young man and and then I
was like oh wow well I started thinking
and this may not be right but I started
thinking and feeling like oh one of the
reasons that you know possibly one of
the reasons that this young man doesn't
want to move out and doesn't want to
grow up is because his dad is gone it's
like it's kind of like we don't want to
if the person who you know who we care
about the most or one of the people that
you want to see us grow up the most
isn't there then sometimes we just will
stop evolving will stop we won't grow up
and it's just that that way it's like
[ __ ] it's like saying [ __ ] you to the
world it's like saying oh you're gonna
take my dad away you're not gonna let
the person that I won't care about the
most be here to see me grow up then [ __ ]
you I'm not growing up and and it's like
the only thing we can do but cuz you
know there's no other way to get back at
time or to get back at the world than by
our own actions really and so we just
stay where we are we say okay time
you're gonna keep going on but I'm gonna
stay right where I am you're not gonna
get me
I'm not flowing in your river you know
I'm not flowing forward I'm not evolving
you know cuz the person I want to be or
the most you took them away well I'm
gonna stay right where I [ __ ] am I'll
show you you know this kid this kind of
invisible I'll show you to the world to
the world that took away your parent or
took away somebody you cared about but
at a certain point you just start to
hurt yourself you know at a certain
point it's like you know you're 30 or
you're getting older and you're still
with at home and and now it's like you
know it's just it's cumbersome on the
young fellas mother and she's getting
older and he needs to be able to
contribute and and I'm not airing his
dirty laundry out there like I'm not
even I'm not ashamed of the guy or I
mean this is just his life this is
what's going on we're all just you know
people that are trying but but yeah at a
certain point he owes it to the adult
him to try and you know to try and get
past it and I understand the
you know him wanting to stay young
forever and stay right where he is and
and nobody else is if you know if he
stays them with his mom then where
there's not really space for another man
to come into the home and like you know
it kind of like it just hits him just at
a core level that's holding on to
everything so much work you know to what
it was like when he was a kid but he
owes it to an adult him sometimes to
move on you know because then then the
adult him as an experience as a chance
to live in the world and have an
experience but it just it made me think
about a lot of things that made me think
about you know how it made me think
about what are ways that when things
happen to me that I would then like try
and connect then try and control the
world so that I could show the world you
know who's boss you know like oh okay
world you're gonna I don't know I can't
think of some kind of but but I could
heavily relate to what this boy went you
know in a way like I could see like wow
sometimes if though if something happens
to us then we hold a grudge against the
world and we can carry it out in ways
that over time aren't really helpful to
us anymore but it's so wild to see like
you know you see this boy trapped in
this man's body and the the the man's
body the adult wants to move on but
there's his boy just like holding on to
like this you know this grudge honestly
against the world and it's a fair grudge
you know the world took his father but
it's it's an unfair grudge in the sense
that
he's not being fair to himself now you
know to the adult him that wants to
really feel free to to challenge the
world and to take on the world and also
maybe don't know what the [ __ ] I'm
talking about but thank you guys so much
for your caring concern for your calls
for helping make this podcast and the
hotline into a frickin you know we're
shooting an actual episodes of a TV show
that's goofy and funny and engaging and
helpful man it's crazy you know it's
just like even if it doesn't even get
picked up by Comedy Central I mean who
knows I mean they picked up some real
clunkers over the years but um but I'm
hopeful that it will and I'm hopeful
that we have a great experience over
there because I know that we have a good
audience and and we got a special kind
of funny and I'd love to see it ah maybe
get embraced over there and have an
opportunity but if not it's already been
a really great experience just being
able to be to meet some just listeners
of the podcast and be a part of their
lives even for this a couple of days you
can go to Ridge wallet comm slash Theo
and use the code th EO at check out for
10%
that's code th EO for 10% off at Ridge
wallet comm if you're tired of carrying
things in the back ear pocket and having
that booty that little booty hump you
know a wallet sometime people will look
at your pants and like oh what happened
did that guy do a real like a strong
duty or something in his pocket and then
try to hide money in it
no that's a wallet and it needs to
evolve because times change and I asked
you to change the times and get that new
front pocket carry the ridge wallet is a
very I got mine right here that Ridge
wallet here this
that ain't ASMR baby
that's our idge that's that Ridge hitter
and it's that front pocket carry it
minimizes all the stuff you're carrying
around if you give a wallet with your
birth certificate in it you know some
scratch-and-sniff pictures of some old
Cocker
something from junior high get rid of
that [ __ ] brah carry around the things
you need most and get that Ridge wallet
it's a front pocket carry let's take a
couple calls as always the hotline nine
eight five six six four nine five zero
three man I wish I had me a piece of
grade block pizza right now let's hit
the hotline hey what's up Theo this is
Andrew from Alabama
hey Andrew thank you for calling and I
have a sister-in-law that lives down in
Alabama and um and she has two boys and
uh and they are beautiful kids and
they're she's a really really good woman
her name is Holly and she's always been
a nice uh she's always been a special
person I've had in my life and her boys
are really good kids one of them has a
birthday coming up anyway don't know why
I told you all that let's go gang gang
gang coming in because I don't even know
how to begin man um you said often in
your podcast about how you feel
uncomfortable for a good majority of the
time and I experienced that I relate to
that man you talk a lot about how most
of your childhood was just being
uncomfortable and just anxious and
constantly worried and afraid to believe
in yourself and just dealing with a lot
of self-doubt you know I relate to that
man I get it because everything
everything scares me to death man I
don't have any confidence I don't have
any time stuff worse it's like I just
somebody tells me that they care about
me or they love me or I get good at
something and I'm just like and so my
question is how you deal with that I got
you get over the the doubt and the fear
and being uncomfortable I mean you know
I've had a lot of people tell me well
you should go talk to somebody let's see
a therapist or something and it just I
feel like and there's nothing wrong with
that but for me I feel like I should be
able to rise above those probably them
home but I don't have the slightest clue
how and I just wondering if you had any
advice er any suggestions there's some
encouragement I love the show keep doing
what you're doing
Gang Gang
Gang Gang brother and thank you for
reaching out from Alabama and uh and
kudos to nick saban minute neva reminds
me of Bill Belichick and even you know
and I know I know that all Alabama isn't
University of roll tide fans but you
know you may be an Auburn fan you may be
a USA fan you may be a you know Mobile
state but but anyway Nick Saban is
amazing and Bill Belichick and him
remind me of each other um I just said
that cause I was trying to relate to you
on some way about football in Alabama
but yeah man is so funny while you're
talking some of those things man you
really reminded me of myself in some
ways you know just the uncomfortability
you know just never feel like I just
never felt like uh just uncomfortable
man just not a comfort not a comfort in
me and so then I would spend more time
by myself after a while and because I
knew then I would at least be I wouldn't
be displaying that uncomfort to others
you know and for me it happened I think
someone just didn't tell me when I was
young at what my feelings were and what
I was feeling and that it was okay even
if when you're young if you feel
uncomfortable somebody says hey if
you're uncomfortable right now it's okay
then that sets a whole different
narrative in your head that now if I
feel uncomfortable oh it's okay it's
just something that's happening and I'll
be back I'll be fine yeah you can go see
someone if you want to mana my
experience with therapy one on one has
not been as helpful as 12-step programs
have been so you know and I'll say this
a lot of times I go to you know I'll go
to different meetings and 12-step and
AAA meetings and that sort of thing
because for me I need a group experience
I need to see others learn to help me
learn in real time I need to see it all
go on this I need a strong proof and and
so that's where I get it and people say
you might say well I'm not
all like I'm not on drugs that's fine
dude I don't know if I'm an alcoholic or
a drug addict I really don't but I but
the program is so great I don't give a
[ __ ] if I am the program so great I stay
in because it's great because there's so
many benefits but it helped me was
starting to realize that it just helped
me with the way I related to myself and
it helped me man I just I felt more
self-worth I felt less uncomfortable I
felt more confident in the space that I
was in
it gave me an environment to shine
emotionally that's what being in 12-step
program helped me do and people will say
we can't drink anymore you came to me I
don't give a [ __ ] bruh
my life has been great my life has been
great there's nothing there's a couple
moments Rob wanting a drink you know or
to do a big booty rail you know do that
[ __ ] ride that white lightning bruh
you know let that electric eel just
slither up into my [ __ ] cranial boy
you know start looking for the Lord but
for the most point I don't but I think
that you can have it a you know it's
almost like the the 12-step programs
they give me like a wading pool where I
can learn humanity at a comfortable
space before being back out in the deep
end of regular life and when I get back
out there I'm doing you know I can doggy
paddle now you know I could swim a
little whereas before I was just
fighting the currents constantly and
just man just I just got to feel okay I
got to seem okay to others that was the
biggest thing and you mentioned
something about that let's go back to
that man and I experienced that I relate
to that man you talk a lot about how
most of your childhood was just you
being uncomfortable and just anxious and
constantly worried and afraid to believe
in yourself and just dealing with a lot
of self-doubt you know I'll relate to
that man I get it because everything
everything scares me to death man it's
like I don't have any coffee
I don't have any time yeah things scare
me to death man recently this weekend I
got so scared about you know be getting
older man it really just scared me
god I hated it and I had that moment you
think that everybody's gonna be gone and
you're gonna be gone and all the people
you love are gonna be gone and and man
it just really scared me
so I'm glad to be here in this moment
now where I'm not there well I'm
connecting with somebody and you know it
I'll say this I didn't believe that
there was a different experience in the
world than the one that I was having and
then I tried some different things I
tried the 12-step recurrent stuff and I
had a new experience do you talking to
somebody I'm not the kind of dude I'm
not buying all the snake oil I don't
[ __ ] you know I don't watch storm
chasers you know what I'm saying daddy I
mean look I [ __ ] love looking for the
rain but and I might want you know if
they had a so called gravity hunters I
might watch a couple episodes but I want
you know you know I I don't find myself
to be very emotionally gullible but when
I came into those environments man in
these rooms and these 12-step rooms sure
like that dude there was something
different I had a different experience
with the world as I knew it brought
shocked me and then I started to get
over some of those things because I
didn't care you know you're
uncomfortable in the world that you're
in but though maybe your perception of
the world that you're in isn't accurate
and you needed somebody maybe when you
were young to tell us you know we need
somebody when we're young to tell us
we're okay
to just if we're scared to recognize it
you know because we win it and say hey
it's okay if you're scared I you know
I'm here for you don't be scared I got
you you know everything's okay you can
be scared if you want for a little bit
but you don't have to be scared forever
you know we need somebody to tell us
those things when we're little and if we
don't get them then that fear just stays
inside of us I think
kind of just just vibes up and down our
spine just like a little light you know
like electricity like that like them big
Siemens in a lava lamp
so but those are things that worked
there opee
you know it's definitely been helpful
but it's been a longer slower road
I think group therapy could be something
that would be really really cool I like
the experience of Exile like the
experience of therapy and in the in a
setting with other people because a lot
of times I can only learn when I see
someone else have a moment where they
learn and then it makes me learn about
me you know when I see somebody really
have an emotional moment and they you
know really have some feelings go off
inside of them and man and then I and
then I react to that it shows me wow you
know you know I do care about others I
am having a real experience I'm gonna
have a super helpful but but don't be
too hard on yourself either but all
those things can be solved in a NAA I
think can be a good solution and you get
new friends man - it is [ __ ] dope
let's take another call here we go yeah
I'm Andrew from Northern California
what's up Andrew thank you for calling
man Northern California and that's a
beautiful area up there a beautiful man
great place to get some [ __ ] weed and
get some clean water
let's go figure that going this weekend
because he's one of those best first
weekend situations I'll ask again
my dad died so I'm sorry to hear that
man I'm sorry too to hear to hear about
that homework graph to call now or
wouldn't apply anymore
so basically warning to all your
listeners something that you know about
already very big changes that my father
got is 54 homes for lung cancer addicted
all his life cigarettes sorry one who's
12 but ended with Matt you know so Wow
no that's big problem for a lot of
people in America oh yeah so now trying
to spread the warning
nothing but another what the [ __ ] about
I was here though
gang gang brother I'm so sorry to hear
that your father passed away man I'm
sorry man
you know I can't really imagine you know
I can't imagine what that's like in a
fresh take an addiction is powerful I
think it's it's very kind of you to
reference that you know to reference
that you know he even though summer was
his own choice to smoke or to you know
to do drugs he has some choice in there
but also when it comes to addiction
there's not the ability to choose is
very very heavily weighted in against
you the ability to really have an
influence on yourself once addiction is
really got its grips on you and I think
it's uh it's very kind of you to
recognize that about your father instead
of you know just pointing the finger
you're kind of you know just you're just
saying hey you know I know that a lot of
this was addiction but I'm sorry man
you know I'm really sorry that that
happened and you know I was just talking
about this yesterday with somebody that
I hate I hate sometimes you when you
don't when something happens real that's
real tough and someone's like that you
don't know what to say
doesn't that isn't that a bummer you
know you don't know how to you know you
don't know what to say
and it's not your responsibility to make
somebody feel okay but it's like you
don't you know you know words can't
really express or say what what I want
to say I don't think I mean I want to
say something that makes you feel okay
you know I want to say something that
makes you feel loved and cared about and
something that you know reminds you that
your father cared about you and
something that you know I want to say
something that makes you know
with a hundred percent reality that you
will see your father again sometime but
but there's nothing really to say to do
all that but I do believe that and and I
think it's sweet of you to share with us
and I bet your father was very proud of
you you know you sound like guy you're a
young man that's very understanding and
and what strength it must take to be
understanding of addiction in a moment
when it's the very thing that took your
your father man that's pretty powerful I
mean that's almost that's really
unconditional love right there because a
lot of people would just say off you
know would be angry you would they would
just be angry at their dad
oh [ __ ] him [ __ ] you you know he didn't
take care of them he didn't do this and
yeah there could be a little bit of that
but the fact that you're understanding
enough to know that uh that the power of
addiction is this whole tug-of-war
that's going on that's constantly you
know really really pulling away at UM at
people's ability to choose man I bet
your dad was pretty I bet he marveled a
lot of your ability to be understanding
and your uh just to you know to
recognize that even in a moment like
this that's pretty powerful man but are
my thoughts will be with you brother and
uh and just take care of yourself you
know take care of yourself man addiction
is uh it is hereditary as well love you
man
let's take another call here we go and
yeah the cigarettes I know about it man
man it and it kills your ability to
relate to others because when I need a
friend or when I need a God or when
honey instead of that I go to a
cigarette sometimes and then it's
whatever else I needed that was gonna be
very real in my life I don't get that I
just get this little hit homework
hey what's up do it's Nate from Indiana
dirty Nate from Indiana and I saw a tow
truck hit an owl one time in Indiana and
that's true over there on I think 52 or
5753 whatever it was going for mining
Annapolis to Bloomington homeward I just
listened to one of your podcast from
January eighth and again you were
talking about being scared really I
understand man mmm-hmm he's saying you
were talking about being scared in a
relationship let's hear more
you made some analogy about something to
do with seeing a lake and someone
telling you to swim well back in the day
they just toss your ass in the lake and
you'll learn to swim and you're a smart
boy still I think I think you learn to
swim for your return all right love you
man bye gang bruh love you man umm yeah
I think you're right dude I think I have
all these reservations sometimes about
relationship and getting married and
settling down and a lot of it is just
fear and if I would just put myself into
it I would probably manage I would
probably manage okay
you're probably right man and I just
hope I find some willingness to do that
you know cuz I really think I do want
the outcomes of uh of a life with
someone else or a life with a family and
being able to be a father and stuff like
that but I appreciate you even thinking
enough about it - I'll give me a buzz
about it homework yeah this is well down
in Fort Myers Florida with so will Fort
Myers dude the great place to get
sunburned and a [ __ ] you know and
some [ __ ] they got some brown tits
down there let's hear more Sunday
evening along the way home from watching
that Superbowl right now Tom Brady and
all I can think about is having a heater
a damn sugar on the way home
oh yeah boy you want that [ __ ] face
header boy no I'm saying you won't bad
oh we're just looking for some words of
encouragement man them on day 10 and
those cigarettes Wow Wow I'll do well
you want some encouragement dude let me
take you - right here bro here's your
encouragement dude always like
cigarettes sorry when you spoke but
ended with Matt you know so there you go
Daddy
cigarettes a damn figure out the way
home
indeed when he was started with
cigarettes and the meth man it's a
gateway drug
you know cigarettes - meth what else you
might go to [ __ ] in you know I say
drywall a lot of people if they start
hanging drywall doing construction
it could be meth in now drywall is a
gateway drug brother be careful out
there
okay you got ten days let's hear more
some words of encouragement man on day
ten and no cigarettes something's
sucking down there swirly dope hitters
like crazy mmm anyways man I know you've
been dealing with that if I get some
help any suggestions I appreciate that
and thanks again for everything do man
onward
oh we're brother that's amazing man well
you know look uh it's I think it's
warming you know to the gentleman whose
father passed away that you're calling
trying to fight it man because look the
world will put a lot of [ __ ] out there
that we can't fight you know they got
pornography at such high definition we
can't fight that you can't your senses
can't it the dopamine you get hooked
cigarette you get a hook these companies
want you hooked they don't want no
freemasons out they don't a free man out
there you wanna talk about a modern-day
slavery man I'll tell you what it is
it's these corporations and their
ability to hold us and to own us with
their medicines in there and their
elixirs and their fancy you know
different types of [ __ ] bruh that's
what's happening we gettin held down by
these corpse
and we got to stay strong and I don't
know if you're still on day 11 now but
if you are good luck and if you aren't
man that I'm sorry but you can start
over you know I just set up an
appointment with my doctor to possibly
get chantix you know I'm doing good with
the cigarettes but I'm not done you know
what they honestly man I've been
thinking about it even during this this
taping and I don't want to do it because
I don't like the way it makes me feel it
makes me agitate it and that makes me a
jeté tit towards others it makes me feel
uncomfortable it makes me feel ashamed
of myself and it makes me feel like I'm
not going to have the future that I want
because I'm not going to be alive to
share it but at the same time if you're
out there smoking man [ __ ] I'm sorry
brought me to get in all of this [ __ ]
because I ain't trying to ruin your vibe
but if you want to quit I am trying to
support your vibe but if you're enjoying
I mean you don't you know then you go
and join them Gang Gang man let's take a
call I'm going to your Columbus show and
I wanted to nominate a single mom oh
well thanks jettison man I appreciate
that yes I would love to to do something
special with a single mom this weekend
in Columbus tell me more bruh podcast
you talked about turning Keira Drabek
she used to live with me and my wife
last year as two year old baby girl and
unless she could use a night out phone
number for me is five okay we'll keep
your phone number out of it thank you
all right man thank you we will reach
out to her that's very nice of you and
that's sweet that she's got a
two-year-old girl it sounds like you and
your wife tried to be of service and you
know I was thinking a lot about that man
that I want to have a child and you know
and I would like to adopt some children
as well you know you know if God blesses
me you know where my higher power
blesses me with uh you know with enough
money to have a household in an
environment where I have enough space to
have extra children and then I really
would consider it you know I think I
would want to take some more classes and
stuff on parents
learn about that kind of stuff more but
you know my I watched my brother be a
parent and my sister and I know that you
know we have it in our genes to be able
to do it and you know I just want to be
able to have a you know have that be
part of my life when I'm ready to you
know when I'm ready to grow up fully and
that's a funny thing that I remembered
about that kid that he reminded me of
that we shot the episode with is that
man I I want to stay sometimes too man
you know I don't want to let that little
kid inside of me I don't want to let him
grow up without all the things that he
wanted because they're not there but at
a certain point that kid that time is
gone and the best thing I can do for
that kid is let him become an adult
let's take one more call here and thank
you we'll reach out to that single mom
that's a great idea and I look forward
to meeting this young lady if it works
out onward blade creaking OH
Covington Lousiana and that's my town
that's where I grew up in over there
then I grew up there off Ali Road out
there you know and um and right off a
Maggie Street over there as well and so
I spent some good time out there in
Covington Lousiana and this boy's name
is Blake homeward look first off he's
from my hometown not being a piece of
[ __ ] I think that's super cool anyway my
question is thank you that's nice he to
say man I mean I I think I probably am a
piece of [ __ ] but it's nice that you
haven't recognized it yet but no I was
fortunate to grow up in a place like
that there was a lot of you know
Covington has a lot of history and
folklore and you know and a lot of good
people man I mean there was a there was
a lot of good people and and I enjoyed
it man and it was you know it was fun
and I had fun and I got to you know you
know it was it was scary but it was fun
but it helped me you know it was where I
started out and I'm grateful oh we're
we're about to have a baby born in July
okay you have a wife from Europe and
you're about to have a baby boy in July
and on the table is foreskin
what did you two say on the table the
table
on the table is forcing the hot debate
is shopping or not oh I thought you
meant it was on the damn table dude I
thought you had that [ __ ] laid out on
the [ __ ] table like a damn appetizer
fool I was like I think this but to
report this young fella which wouldn't
surprise me sure out of Covington
Louisiana if people sitting around
having a couple of you know you know a
little [ __ ] circumcision on a cracker
let's hear more so it's on it's a hot
topic of debate your wife's from Europe
I'm in favor one day in on this also uh
so British swaps quit when tightening
this is we hardly yeah I will tell
Brandon showers at and this is the deal
brother this is where we are with this
circumcision get it done man you can't
be running around with extra dick he
ain't got the dick to back it up
you know you see these thing the people
they got extra dick meet at the entered
you know they got a little dick at that
they turtleneck in out there they dick
look like a long sleeve you know like a
wizard or something
you can't do that [ __ ] it looked like
their dick is like looking for something
you can't do that [ __ ] because then you
pull the thing back
you still got regular amount of dick on
the inside so you frontin with big dick
and you showing up with mid medium dick
I don't know I'll just show up with
medium dick front with medium Dickens
show up with medium day you know people
want to say want to throw it out that
long neck you know and but then you know
that you pull all the skin back and all
you got that little critter just show up
with a regular critter
so I say cut it off man but save it do
it a lot of that [ __ ] has stem cells in
it now do you drink a couple of those
[ __ ] breath a little bit of jmo and
some [ __ ] stem cells off your baby
boys [ __ ] chirp rod sing Harry Mary
now you mean next level baby watch your
[ __ ] opera house grow in thicker Sun I
think you got a real chance to [ __ ]
meet the Lord like that so I said you
got a church do you can't have that bull
with that long you know somebody dick
got a long neck on and get the [ __ ] out
of here
dick looks like it's in the dang the
Shriners Club or something like it's got
one of them hats on it and in things
people they do tricks with him and stuff
people put coins in there they got a
dude on internet he put a hole you know
like a roll of quarters he did all that
and his extra wiener skin man we're
better than that man so I say clip that
thing out feed it to a bird or something
if you have to give it back to mother
nature
but if not mine just at least save it
put you know freeze that bad boy freeze
that bad boy up I want to thank
everybody that came out and listened
this week you know I'm still trying to
catch up on some rest we're shooting the
rest of the pilot but I'm grateful for
you guys I appreciate y'all being here
and dealing with me and you know the
past couple months have been a little
stressful because I've been tired but
trying to manage a little bit better and
what else man just thank you so much you
don't even know what to say right now
ah and I don't have to say anything and
I don't know what you need to hear but
you know to the guy you feeling
uncomfortable a lot of times it's okay
bro you know but don't but be brave
enough to try something new so you can
maybe have a new experience that's the
only thing and also don't be ashamed of
the way that you are you know sometimes
we take words and we say it's one thing
but really we're you know if you feel
uncomfortable you might just be more
emotionally aware than other people and
when we're more emotionally aware we're
gonna notice more things going on inside
of us than other people who aren't so
some of the things that seem like
burdens could really be blessings
because once you you know if there's a
way to realize then put that emotional
awareness to use you know with raising
your own kids and you're gonna say
things to them that your parents
wouldn't have said to you because you
interact with the world differently and
you're gonna tell your kid hey
everything you are okay right now you
know and everything's okay and you can
feel this way but it for a little bit
but you can also feel this way and feel
proud of yourself and feel you know
nobody's judging you know there's things
you're gonna be able to tell because
your awareness of the world is going to
be different so you're gonna share a
different experience with your son or
your daughter so those are cool gifts
man but yeah man it's a great time to be
alive this is it this is our life this
is our life and if it's not going great
it could be going better
you know but we have to do we have to
make we have to be willing to make some
adjustments and sometimes I am sometimes
I'm not but you know God bless you the
young man whose father passed away
gagging gagging to the gentleman who's
still going on he's got eleven days
today on those cigarettes yeah sometimes
you got to get in the lake and swim
we'll see that single mom in Columbus I
think we'll be able to work that out and
clip off that we nor meet bra David
ain't nowhere you know and you get more
pink I too like that I hurt and you know
I'm against that right now cuz I'm
[ __ ] low keeper been rocking that [ __ ]
gang gang man you guys be good to
yourselves I hope that you deserve it I
bet you do
Oh
celebrate
celebrate our day
Oh
sighs
let's have some fun while we all die